[Music]
exciting to be here well as as mark said
uh i am the the founder and the faculty
of the khan academy
um
very bureaucratic organization
uh uh and as he said there you know i
started off just a little background on
me i i kind of have a techie background
math background
and then i sold out and i became an
analyst at a hedge fund
but but while i was an analyst at a
hedge fund i still i always had this
little bit of a of an itch to teach and
i and i i no one believes me but my
motivation for working at a hedge fund i
didn't even know
someone told me it's the best job to
learn about everything you get to see
what happens to crop prices when an oil
tanker in this part of the world
disappears and then that happens in gold
that's a great job and then someone else
had an end at pace pretty well i said
well that's a but but i was working at a
at a i sold out i was working at a as an
analyst at a hedge fund and i started
tutoring uh my cousins in new orleans
and we would do this kind of remote
tutoring type of thing we'll talk more
about the form factor because that's
what i really want to make this talk
about
and
i wanted to scale up so i just started
making i started making youtube videos
and and fast forward you know about four
or five years and as mark said is now
1400 videos uh starts i started just
doing algebra and after about 70 videos
i said
gee that's that's algebra and and this
was kind of a part-time thing for me and
then i said well maybe i could do
pre-algebra too and then another 70
videos later i said that's pre-algebra
i'll do trigonometry and maybe calculus
and maybe i'll do arithmetic and i'll do
physics and and before we know it fast
forward there's 1400 videos like mark
had mentioned and
the youtube people told me that it's now
the most used open course video library
on definitely on youtube uh more views
than mit and stanford and berkeley and
as far as i know the the internet and
this is all from
this is
this
and and this is all from one dude who is
you know a guy working at a hedge fund
and is part-time with no budget
whatsoever
really just starting to tutor his
cousins and and and you know now 60 000
video views
and and uh 14 million views 200 000
unique students a month and you know you
can kind of view it as it's the largest
school in the world but before i go into
the actual you know why and i want to
make this kind of a conversation about
why i think it's working because i think
it has it can be moved to other domains
in all of our lives i think and i think
it'll tell us something about how we
learn and all of that i want to show you
a quick video just so you understand the
form factor and then we can talk a
little bit about
why maybe we collectively think it might
be working so if you start up the video
4 x squared squared
plus two times the product of both terms
two times four x squared
times y squared
plus
y squared this term
in october of 1805
the french navy gets destroyed by the
british in the battle of trafalgar
this is trafalgar it's actually written
here tre
falger and they get destroyed by
napoleon's good old friend admiral
horatio nelson
horatio nelson so this guy was
definitely a thorn in napoleon side
horatio
d8 positive
t cell it has the cd8 proteins on it and
this would be called a cd4 positive
c d for positive t cells
p of x y i
plus q of x y
j right this is just a vector field over
problem 34.
a landscaper estimates that landscaping
a new park will take one person
48 hours
if four people work on the job and they
each work six hour days they each work
six hour days
so
and i'm curious and don't feel free you
know i i'm very open to the negative
feedback uh what are the things you know
if you just were to compare that to to
your experience when you might have been
exposed to some of those same concepts
either
when you learned it in high school or in
college or even if you've watched some
of you know the other online video
libraries out there what are the things
that that stood out to you that that
were a little different any
fast forward
yeah no that's actually a huge and i
think that's online video in general
this and the comment was you can fast
forward and
you know and i was going to talk about
this later but there's this whole notion
that anything online is kind of just a
nice to have it's not as good as a live
interaction and i think that assumption
is something that you know this is bias
that we always have in life that
something for free that is has a has
zero incremental delivery cost has got
to be worse than something that's really
expensive and hard to do
and and and if you think about it i mean
you know there there is value of being
in a room together i think you know
something like gel it's like a shared
experience we can get inspired together
but if we're if it's like a broadcast
lecture and it's kind of mundane and no
one's really you know there's not a lot
of interaction it's an interesting
question to say gee is is video in any
way
less good than a an actual live
interaction and and because you can
pause you can repeat it you can you
don't have to be take notes it is
actually something that as far as i can
tell better in every way you watch it on
your own terms whenever you want to
watch it if you don't understand a
concept you can watch a previous video
you can look on wikipedia and see what
that word meant so yeah that is one of
the and i would say that's general of on
all online videos not just the kind of
academy any other things that just kind
of popped out when you saw those videos
pleasing the teacher in other words you
weren't distracted by the social
interaction you're just listening
right so the comment was that you're not
worried about pleasing the teacher but
you're just doing it for your own
benefit and that's actually when i
started
like my my teaching career and it's full
time now i quit my job in in september
um
i was i was i was tutoring my cousins
and i was doing it remotely they were in
new orleans i was i was in boston i'm in
northern california and they were doing
really well but then i started doing
these youtube videos and i assumed it
was not going to be as good as the live
interaction i said no this is just a
nice to have for them
you know it maybe other people will
watch it and i kind of said it was a
little bit of a legacy maybe uh my you
know my great grandchildren might be
able to watch learn calculus from these
videos so you know i just thought it
would be a nice thing uh to put out
there but the the first point of
feedback i got from my cousins and it
was a little bit of a backhanded
compliment is that you're better on
youtube than you are in person
and
after a little bit of you know getting
not being defensive about that i think
they were saying exactly this when we
had the live interaction the one-on-one
session that's stressful for the student
that's stressful oh you get this and
they might kind of get it it might be
like an 80
understanding of it but they don't want
to waste my time and i'm their cousin
i'm volunteering they don't they don't
want me to judge them in any negative
way so oh yeah yeah i get it but that's
bad information for me i'll move on to
the next concept they're stressed out
the whole time they want this whole
interaction to be over but with this you
you're not afraid to ask the question
the question literally is you go to that
you know as mark said there's 1400
videos you're like you know what i'm a
little shaky on negative numbers even
though i'm in calculus there's no way in
a traditional classroom that you'll have
the guts to raise your hand say wait
what a negative times why is that a pot
you you can't do that
but now you know youtube you can kind of
pause the videos let me let me go watch
the video just just to make sure i
understand that uh properly any other
things popped out
right here
yeah so so the comment was that it uh it
the colors and it i repeat a lot and and
i i cater to different learning styles
and i'll throw out another one i think
it's related is that you don't see me
you don't you don't see the the teacher
and i'll tell you
huh
but you can hear me exactly exactly and
and and i'll tell you why i did it i
want to make it sound like i'm this you
know grand designer and i had all of
this you know interesting ideas in my i
did it initially because i did not have
a video camera
and
and i thought well when i when i when i
did it with my cousins in new orleans
they didn't see me either but it seemed
to be working with them all they heard
was my voice on the speakerphone and we
had like a shared notepad we were using
yahoodoodle at the time and if i wrote
something they would see it if they
wrote something i would see it and we
made the i just like
i'm you know if i don't know if there's
like a movement for against or four
whiteboards but i hate whiteboards i
think black is just like there's this
emptiness it's just like the universe
and then you can start kind of putting
in little bits of and it seems like such
a subtle thing but for me like you know
that one video where you see the white
background it's it's kind of like a
struggle for me i need that that cleans
like literally a clean slate uh
but but i did it because it worked with
my cousins and and i didn't have a video
camera but as soon as i as i put it out
there like that
the feedback i immediately got from from
people on youtube is
it feels intimate even though they know
that it's a recording and i'm not really
there they said it actually feels like
you're sitting next to me
tutoring me it doesn't feel like you
know think about the other experience
where i'm all the way over here you know
on a chalkboard and the next step and
i'm projecting
over to you and you're you're distant
you're not in any way connected with a
teacher when you have kind of this voice
in your in your head it feels it and you
know actually some people said it feels
even more it feels like not only are we
sitting actually it feels like you're
actually in my brain
that i'm i'm i'm i and and even more
i've actually gotten several people say
that when i take the exam
when as soon as it like you know when i
think in other domains i have a normal
voice
but as soon as i see a calculus problem
it's like well and the next and you hear
you you
so it's uh any other any other notions
yeah the audio is consistent unlike in a
classroom where you know the teacher
turns around and you can't hear oh yeah
no that's another thing that's uh you
know that is actually one of my
motivations for doing is i looked before
i started i looked at a lot of the stuff
i'm not the first person putting videos
i looked at the mit stuff which i think
is great uh and has like you know it the
it was the video camera was at that same
seat i i i went to mit and i it's like
the same seat i used to sit in and like
fall asleep in and like and and and you
know sometimes and
i think some tremendous what they did i
don't know if anyone realizes the
history of this open course thing and
like 2000 or 2001 was all happening
every other university was thinking
about a for-profit model distance
learning mit said no everything's for
free so i think it's like this hugely
awesome thing they did but it's hard to
to see what's going on in the classroom
and and and the other feedback i get is
that the lecture is actually distracting
we naturally want to engage with the
human eyes and the hands and that's what
you want to look at you don't want to
look at the math and when the
professor's there that's what you look
at and you get disengaged and and any
other any other
here
go at your own speed exactly there you
can go exactly
some people have actually they've
written little apps that actually will
speed up or slow down the actual without
changing the pitch
oh yeah exactly
exactly and that's the thing that
shocked me i thought this is for my
cousins they can fill in their blanks
but over and over again i got letters
from gifted students and parents saying
that this allowed my students and people
with learning disabilities that say and
people with attention death disorder
thing so it's all of these things that
just kind of fell into place and i'll
tell you kind of the other thing that i
think makes it very different is it's
just conversational because you know
some of it is because the form factor is
is it feels like i'm next to you i get
to kind of chat about it with you as
opposed to you know being pedantic and
sitting at a board the next step i i can
i can be very natural
and the other you know a lot of people
uh say how do you prepare for these
videos and and and can i have a
transcript or can i have uh
and and and what i say is there is none
like when i turn on the video it is
literally a train of thought process it
isn't uh it isn't scripted in any way
and and
i started doing that actually out of
laziness
i i you know it's for my cousins what do
i care actually a few of the videos i
actually answered telemarketer calls
during
the video
and
but but
but but the takeaway and you know all of
these things i've done out of laziness i
now can say oh this is brilliant and all
but but but the takeaway that the p that
people love to see
and you never get to see it anywhere
else i mean just like reflect back on
your entire education career everything
you saw was the finished product the
professor when they teach that concept
to you they had done that problem 20
times before they review the solution
manual and they just give you the
finished product they're just like oh
you're an idiot if you just don't
immediately do step a b c and d
but when you watch these videos and i
guarantee you like 95 of the videos when
i'm doing it on screen i have never seen
the problem before and every now and
then every now and then i make mistakes
i forget a negative sign or i go down a
path that was not the right path but the
but this
i get this probably the single issue i
get the most emails about
people say it makes me comfortable with
mathematics it allows me to see the art
it allows me to see someone who
looks like they know what they're doing
but they too stumble every now and then
they sometimes go down the wrong path
and you can kind of see out loud
the thought process of of going through
this and and you know the one thing you
know mark said tell us about what what
you really think makes makes khan
academy a stand out and why it seems to
have struck a chord with people and
i think it's kind of an artifact of how
my own brain works i'm this
i don't know whether i was exposed to
something or this is just how i learned
to learn but
i'm almost i cannot process anything
unless it's distilled down into really
really really simple nuggets and it's
almost
it's almost obvious by the time like and
and it was it was it was almost
difficult when i was in school to be
like if you just gave me a formula and
said just apply that formula steps a b
and c i like my brain just start i can't
do it i'm go and so i would like fall
behind in class and because i wanted to
pop play with the equations and make
connections and understand why it was
interesting and and and and what's it's
really saying about the universe and but
but later on obviously that became a
huge asset because uh in 11th grade when
you get exposed to a concept you're like
oh well you know i spent i invested all
that time in eighth grade and this
concept that they're saying is a new
concept that's just that eighth grade
concept and they're just rebranding it a
little bit and it now just looks like
this 11th grade concept and while this
is you know all my peers are getting who
are you know smarter than me are getting
stuck memorizing things and not knowing
what they're doing and then forgetting
things the week after i was like this is
frustrating so my
if i had to say the single biggest goal
in the khan academy is to try to deliver
things the way i wish it was delivered
to me
you get the intuition from the beginning
i will not make a video unless i have an
intuition on the concept the best
example is on entropy
i'm not like you know and when i went
through my education i wasn't like this
thermodynamics jock so i didn't really
you know i i could do the problems and
and i could get the question right but i
said i'm going to make a video on
entropy and i said you know i know how
to you know the steps but none of these
textbooks are really doing the job doing
the trick and really letting me know
what entropy really is and i have just a
suspicion that it's not they're not
saying so i literally i took two weeks
off and i just pondered it and i called
every professor everybody everyone who i
could talk to and i said let's go have a
glass of wine about entropy
and
after about two weeks it clicked in my
brain i was like now i'm ready to make a
video on entropy so if there's one
takeaway from the khan academy is that
it's just focused on narrowly focused on
intuition and just to show you and
really
reinforce the point that
i think and it wasn't obvious
from the get go that this is
this is not just a nice to have this
isn't just something that you know might
make an a minus student into a an a
student or an a plus student i want to
read some of the letters and
and i get on the order of now you know i
get like a couple hundred letters a day
from students and teachers and and
homeschoolers around the world now uh
the content's actually being distributed
in offline servers into ethiopia and
places where they can't even find
teachers
but but these these comments
i mean some of them are nice and funny
and simple but some of them really speak
to
there's there's a deep hunger for this
type of thing and it's just not being
addressed this is a a comment on a
calculus video first time i smiled doing
a derivative
this person did a derivative
and then they smiled
they i remember ap calculus no one was
smiling
and then the next the next come this is
in reply to that response same thing
here i actually got a natural high and a
good mood for the entire day
since i remember seeing all of this
matrix text in class and here i'm all
like i know kung fu
and the underlying theme here the
underlying theme here you know i used to
think when i went through my career that
only like math geeks like me and mark
we're the only type of people that like
to like understand things that everyone
else just wants to but the the takeaway
here is that everyone i don't care
whether you're the math geek or whether
you are the kid who's about to drop out
or or you're the kid who thought they
hated mathematics when you actually
learn something really learn something
not just learn the steps and you know
jump through the hoops when you really
learn something
it's arguably the highest high any human
being can have
and and you see it i mean this is
another like this is a sn an excerpt my
eldest kid is dancing around in my room
here because she is so excited that she
finally found someone that teaches like
this
she did a math problem and then she
danced
now this you know i i i i was working as
an analyst at a hedge fund and and the
site traffic started to take off and and
i said gee you know i would tell my wife
this is so exciting and i want to do
this and people were writing me letters
and uh but but there's no it wasn't
making but you know i said i have some
savings i could quit and i was really on
the edge about this i said i really want
to do this but i can't figure out and
then i got this letter and this letter
and i'll read an excerpt of it it to me
i mean i was like if i only got this
letter this would be worth it but this
is there could be a million people like
this and this person is the only i mean
it's
mr khan no teacher has ever done me any
good this may sound harsh but i mean it
quite literally i was force-fed
medication to keep from talking and
chastised for not speaking when called
on
about five years ago my family collected
enough money to move from where i was
born so i could have a chance at having
an education living in real life but
without a real mastery of elementary
math i was slow to progress i am now in
college and learning more than i ever
have in my life
but an inadequate math background has
been holding me back i found the khan
academy in june of 2009. so it's like a
year ago
right after i completed math 141 a
college algebra course i've spent the
entire summer on your youtube page and i
just wanted to thank you for everything
you're doing this is a godsend last week
i tested for a math placement exam and
i'm now an honors math 200. now this is
the next sentence is the one that really
got me this is on a placement exam this
isn't unlike the regular exam you have
in class where uh you know you know what
you're studying for this is like all of
mathematics this is on the placement
exam the entrance placement exam no
question was answered incorrectly on the
placement exam this was a kid who had
basic deficiencies in mathematics and
they watched youtube videos for summer
and they did not get one question wrong
i can say without any doubt you've
changed my life and the lives of
everyone in my family when you read that
you're like okay screw the hedge fund
world
suddenly thank all of y'all